ein fundstück aus dem meer
ein knopf der einst zu einem hemd
gehörte dass ein mensch getragen hatte
der mensch ist verschwunden in den
endlosen weiten des pazifiks chile ein
land mit fast 5000 kilometer küste das
wasser ist in chile allgegenwärtig in
allen erdenklichen form
die dunklen geheimnisse des wassers
haben patricio guzmán zu seinem film
inspiriert ich erinnere mich daran gern
klassenkamerad von mir verschluckt wurde
seither lässt mich dass mir nicht mehr
los gleichzeitig habe ich ein
ambivalentes verhältnis geprägt von
feucht wie auch von faszination für
viele chilenen ist das meer wie eine
mauer
man war es nicht was dahinter liegt das
meer ist für uns auch eine bedrohung für
die ureinwohner patagoniens war dass mir
die lebensgrundlage
es waren wasser nomaden die 10.000 jahre
im einklang mit der natur lebten 50
jahre genügten den weißen siedlern um
sie auszulöschen pkws karte und andere
stämme wurden opfer eines genozids von
8.000 leben heute noch 20
gabriela rotis chilene
das wasser sagt patricio guzmán habe ein
gedächtnis und er hat es sich zur
aufgabe gemacht die schmerzlichen
erinnerungen wach zu behalten in einem
filmischen nachruf
und allen meinen filmen ist der wunsch
da trauer auszudrücken sich an die
verstorbenen zu erinnern aber
gleichzeitig glaube ich sind meine filme
nicht traurig sie besingen die erde das
leben
die da seins art der chilene
wie die ureinwohner sind auch sie opfer
sie gehören zu den tausenden von
oppositionellen die keynote verhaften
und foltern ließ viele ihrer kollegen
verschwanden spurlos
bussmann rekonstruiert im film mit ihren
leichen mit eisenbahnschienen beschwert
über dem meer abgeworfen wurden
spurensuche 40 jahre später gefunden
wurde dieser knopf patricio guzmán hat
chile bei chats staatsstreich 1973
verlassen
seither lebt er im französischen exil
doch das schicksal vieles bleibt sein
thema manche die lehnen die
rechtsgerichteten hassen meiner arbeit
denn ich höre nicht auf vom
staatsstreich zu reden von kino chat vom
unrecht in chile
doch es gibt auch die anderen die meine
arbeit unterstützen mich motivieren uns
mir helfen das zeigt mir dass viele
heute noch in zwei große blöcke geteilt
in jenen teil der die vergangenheit
vergessen will und in den anderen teil
der auf dieser herkunft aufbauen und
china weiter zu bringen
sein beitrag dazu sind filme in denen es
um menschen geht die verschwunden sind
und die man nicht vergessen darf